sie nennen sie hexe sein kampfname den
ihr die männer im team gegeben haben aus
respekt vor dem krieg war hexe
sportschützen jetzt gehört sie zu den
elite soldat innen der ukraine der
auftrag töten aus dem hinterhalt
einsatzgebiet direkt an der front wir
dürfen sie bei ihrem training begleiten
als einziges ausländisches team meine
tägliche aufgabe ist es zu trainieren
weil jede kampf mission vorbereitung
braucht das gilt für dich persönlich und
für deine waffe dafür fühle ich mich
verantwortlich
scharfschützen das sind spezialisten im
krieg die die ganz nah an die
feindlichen linien gehen ob sie manchmal
angst habe fragen wir sie ja natürlich
ich bin doch ein mensch aber das gehört
natürlich auch zu den fähigkeiten von
scharfschützen wir müssen ruhig werden
wir müssen die angst in den griff
bekommen
hexe will ihr gesicht nicht zeigen will
nicht über details ihrer aufträge
sprechen lieber zeigt sie uns wie sie
sich vorbereitet auf ihre einsätze die
manchmal einen ganzen tag dauern können
du musst eine bequeme und stabile
position finden dann bewegst du deine
finger und zehen so dass es keiner
bemerkt damit sie nicht taub werden weil
es menschliche bedürfnisse anbelangt das
musst du trainieren aushalten können
lange war sie die einzige frau im team
an präzision kann es niemand mit ihr
aufnehmen diesen ruf hat sie sich
erarbeitet
[Musik]
mit dieser waffe das ist ein kaliber 308
die tödliche reichweite ist 900 meter
danach kommt man in eine unter
schallgeschwindigkeit der schuss wird
dann ungenau
hexe ist eine von vielen frauen die für
die ukraine in den krieg ziehen
38.000 soldatinnen gibt es es ist eine
der höchsten frauenquoten weltweit
[Musik]
valentina sven kopka hat sich freiwillig
gemeldet um ihr land zu verteidigen
früher war sie anwältin wir treffen sie
an einem der vielen checkpoints
politisch dumm ich habe mich dazu
entschieden den jungs hier zu helfen es
geht nicht nur darum sie mit essen zu
versorgen die kleidung logistische
probleme zu lösen es geht darum ihn zu
zuhören weil sie in ständiger gefahr
sind
die südliche front ist nicht weit von
hier gerade vermeldet die ukraine in
diesem gebiet erfolge die rückeroberung
einzelner dörfer aber wenn es nötig wäre
kann auch valentinas und oskar sich
vorstellen zur waffe zu greifen
es gibt keinen unterschied zwischen mir
und den männern ich denke sogar dass
frauen motivierter sind
emotionaler emotion
und ja ich bin bereit mein land zu
verteidigen
wie bei so vielen in der südukrainischen
ihre muttersprache russisch jetzt wird
auch zuhause ukrainisch gesprochen das
verhältnis zu russland dem einstigen
oder volk hält valentinas wind oscar für
endgültig zerstört
es ist unmöglich diesen krieg
diplomatisch zu beenden russland hat ja
schon gezeigt wozu es fähig ist nur
waffen können die russen dazu bringen
das land zu verlassen hier weiß jedes
kind wie dringend wir waffen aus dem
ausland brauchen verhandlungen werden
zug gar nichts
auch polizistinnen wie all age of pan
sind jetzt teil der streitkräfte in
nikolajew sollen sie russische
raketeneinschläge dokumentieren sowie
den aus der nacht das örtliche
krankenhaus wurde bombardiert auch unser
dreh wird von sirenen unterbrochen
wieder alarm ja
ist das jetzt gefährlich für uns müssen
wir hier weg
ich denke dass das besser in den
burkhard zu gehen ich glaube es gibt
allen hier
über viele treppen geht es runter in den
luftschutzkeller des krankenhauses durch
verwinkelte flure vorbei an patienten
die liegen müssen
auch ein paar kinder sind hier
olena chan ist selbst mutter sohn und
tochter sind bei der oma sie vermisst
sie
ja immer
wenn es luftalarm gibt wenn russische
raketen im anflug sind und die kinder
nicht hier sind das macht mir angst weil
du einfach nie weißt wo die raketen
einschlagen werden
nach ein paar minuten bekommt sie
unerwartet besuch
das ist jetzt zufall dass ihr euch hier
trefft oder
kann man so sagen er war in der nähe war
jetzt alarm ist habe ich ihm gesagt dass
ich hier bin und mein mann ist zu mir
gekommen um mich zu beschützen
nach 30 minuten gehen alle wieder nach
oben diesmal ist nichts passiert aber
die schäden durch den raketeneinschlag
aus der nacht sind so groß dass
krankenhaus muss evakuiert werden der
krieg hat für die polizisten alles
verändert
darauf wurden wir nicht vorbereitet
wir hatten kein entsprechendes training
und unser job hat sich insgesamt
dramatisch verändert die prioritäten
sind jetzt komplett anders
lena hat heute geburtstag sie zeigt mir
ein foto ihrer kinder was wünscht sie
sich an diesem tag frage ich sie für
sich für die kinder für ihr land
wir freuen uns auf den sieg wenn wir den
erreichen dann haben wir alles wir
können uns erholen unsere träume werden
wahr selbst solche einfachen wie wieder
ein spaziergang durch die stadt zu
machen jeder bürger von nikolov und der
ukraine kämpft dafür dass unsere kinder
in einem freien land leben können
hexe hat keine kinder aber einen klaren
blick auf diesen krieg und hoffnung für
die zeit danach
entwicklung für unser land neugestaltung
europäische integration nur das beste
hexe wird weiterkämpfen für die ukraine
wie so viele andere hat sie sich das bis
vor kurzem nicht vorstellen können
[Musik]